dear dr teddrus distinguished guests
i remember very vividly those days of
april last year
the world had been caught by surprise by
the pandemic
and the response of too many leaders was
my country first
we made a different choice we knew
that we needed to fight this virus not
just at home
but in all continents and all countries
from asia's mega cities to africa's most
remote villages
and for this we needed to act fast
and act together and this is how the act
accelerator was born
i am proud that europe was part of its
inception
from day one and a special thanks
to you dear dr tedros and the team at
who
for getting the act accelerator off the
ground so quickly
and many many thanks also to you
dear serial ramaphosa and dear erna
solberg
for taking on the leadership of the
facilitation council
already in early may 2020 europe
co-hosted a first pledging conference
to raise money for this initiative
many other pledging events followed suit
europe helped raise billions of euros
for act accelerator
but what i really love about
act accelerator is the team spirit
act accelerator wasn't created as a new
institution
but a new way of working together
we all mobilized the world health
organization
and national governments u.n agencies
and
philanthropists ngos
and the pharma industry because every
one of us
has something to contribute act
accelerator brought together
all health actors and empowered them to
do more
and better together
thanks to this cooperation act
accelerator has achieved
so much in so little time
act accelerator helped identify a
life-saving therapy against covet
thanks to act accelerator coveted tests
are now available
in low-income countries for less than
three dollars
and its vaccine pillar covax is now
shipping vaccines
at an affordable price or for free to
over 100 countries
none of us could do this alone
but together we achieved a miracle
every cent that we put into act
accelerator
has been a good investment
and we will need more of this in the
month ahead
because the pandemic is far from over
we need act accelerator perhaps even
more than one year ago to track the
virus as it evolves
to scale up manufacturing to deliver
vaccines to all
corners of the world
act accelerator has a funding gap of
22 billion dollars
the european commission has just doubled
its contribution
and let me invite all governments
but also the private sector to step
up because this is how we can
end the pandemic joining forces
as a team as team human
this is the spirit of act accelerator
and europe is playing for the team
happy birthday act accelerator